it took just over two weeks for the US
to test a land-based intermediate-range
Tomahawk missile following its
withdrawal from the intermediate-range
nuclear forces or INF treaty in early
August the agreement signed at the
height of the Cold War between
Washington and Moscow in 1987 led to the
destruction of thousands of missiles had
long been a source of fear for Europeans
it was clear their countries would be
the battleground in any nuclear war the
u.s. maintains it had no choice but to
withdraw for two reasons
the Russians have long flout of the
agreement something Moscow denies and
China which was not a signatory has been
building up its arsenal of intermediate
missiles these developments by the
Russian Federation in China coupled with
their aggressive and chorus of behaviors
are key drivers behind a deteriorating
security environment the United States
will not and cannot ignore this reality
but Russia says the launch proves what
both the Obama and the Trump
administration's have long denied it's
the u.s. that has been flouting the
treaty with its deployment of what
washington calls a missile defense
system in eastern europe the missile
launcher used in Sunday's test is the
same model that the US has deployed in
Romania and Poland but with
modifications to an hour to launch
offensive intermediate nuclear missiles
and Moscow chided the us's allies for
sitting quietly as Washington
unilaterally nullified another treaty
designed to preserve international
security usually when you pinion my
interests or swim pantech do you really
not understand that what you've done
with the Americans
step by step you're returning to a
historical situation when missiles were
targeting European cities from different
sides
the u.s. is allies however did stick to
Washington's line albeit while
expressing concern about a new arms race
China also stuck to its long-held line
its nuclear arsenal is defensive and
dwarfed by those of Russia and the US so
it's not relevant to this discussion so
we - it is unacceptable to use China as
an excuse for leaving the treaty China
rejects the baseless accusations by the
United States in fact recently the Trump
administration has been making it pretty
clear it left the INF primarily because
of
the US defense secretary even expressing
the hope that soon perhaps in a matter
of months there will be an
intermediate-range conventional missile
capability in the asia-pacific region
there it's unclear which Asian countries
would want to host such missiles and
become a target just as Europe was
during the Cold War
Sheraton C al Jazeera the United Nations